that's gonna break my spirit back
welcome to Spectre seeker it's an oculus
rift horror game it was one of the
finalists of the virtual reality game
damn so I'm expecting something out of
the ordinary because there was a pretty
high quality ones in there but enough
chitchat let's just play well this looks
awesome whoa what whoa this wallpapers
are amazing all right it looks pretty
[ __ ] immersive let's just go we're
going up headed a party I have no idea
what the game is about which is usually
not good for me beautiful curtains kind
of spooky curtains
she knows y'all hey don't look at her
why do they never want me to look at me
is she that ugly she can't be that ugly
it's like she's really really ugly it's
kind of awkward just don't do whatever
you do don't look at it whoa that's kind
of cool
okay it's that guy that looks like that
guy there I hope not I don't whoa
it looks so real with the fog or
whatever whoa
the depths then the death yes thank you
thank you all you have great depth
Vendome that's high whoa
well I have a body hell yeah I'm a body
Oh what is this rescue in the debt okay
I get it
the hell he want from me
all right I'm walking slower than a
turtle on steroids
they don't [ __ ] move at all keep
moving keep moving
how's that okay you can feel her
approach
I really can't you don't know me text I
do you don't who wrote this [ __ ] this is
[ __ ] creepy MA
why is it so slow I danced bath-bot
won't pay for you're not that cool
anymore
okay you know I'm sure it's gonna be
fine
that clock is not it's not a client okay
hadar I hear a girl whispered to me I
don't like it I don't like it and one
bit what the [ __ ] was that not playing
games here someone touched me what the
[ __ ] are you okay I'm not looking no
looking no looking no looking
[Laughter]
[Music]
are you okay dude you're a good damn
[ __ ]
I screamed way to laugh I forget what
I'm doing you I have neighbors they hear
everything I say
sorry neighbors don't look at her they
said it will be fine they said [ __ ]
liars I say okay we're back here [ __ ]
can't [ __ ] with us anymore
can you data thinks that this looks
awesome it looks it's probably one
another prettiest oculus rift games cuz
it's very like ah I want to look at not
the prettiest but its sexiest I don't
[ __ ] know
can you stop west Frank please thanks
the depths why
hey [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] whispering again
I don't know why I wonder how I wonder
why today you told me about the blue
blue sky and all that I can see just
another lemon tree and then Wendy and
Wendy I turned in my head I bend in turn
each and each and attorney turned it
over and and
I can see it's just oh [ __ ] we're going
down there huh [ __ ] I don't want
to go down there hello hello
oh nice water that's what I was hoping
for I was like no it's missing water
yeah is it what does it say it's so
weird
wrong what I didn't mean okay I can hear
the [ __ ] I can hear that [ __ ] don't
like it
where the [ __ ] is she where that [ __ ] it
oh this is [ __ ] terrifying
oh god damn it whoever made this is a
dick okay what is this wrong so that is
the wrong way all right call what the
[ __ ] eyes about a busy job like am i
also feel hand she held back that oh oh
oh just knowing that that [ __ ] is
touching my ass this doesn't make me
feel good at all oh god oh god
Oh dip oh that's an awesome puzzle okay
so if I close my left eye sorry if I
close my right eye it says right if I
close my left eye it says wrong that is
weird
how the [ __ ] did I deal with that so
that means what what the hell was that
how entire jumped up on the table thanks
that guy oh hell man dad oh don't look
at her let's just say that wrong right
this way bros ain't no [ __ ] stopping
when the pewdiepie is popping what's in
here
that ways right that ways right how the
[ __ ] do I know which way I'm just gonna
assume I'm doing it incorrectly whoa
what that's the light the only way take
her picture I'm not taking her picture
what is this how do I take a picture the
only way to survive take her picture
whoa Jeff what the [ __ ] how do I take
pics oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I don't want to
take a picture if I wanted to take a
picture
I'd be hoarding myself out on Facebook
right now god damn it all right [ __ ]
you want a picture you want a picture
I'll Photoshop the [ __ ] out of here come
here I'll make you all Moses
good-looking it and go you're scaring me
stop doing [ __ ] what is that that's a
base [ __ ] where did you go
is that her is that her is that her
now why is she
what the hell is that what is the [ __ ]
no no oh so scary you don't know what
it's like in there don't give me that
look I'm gonna finish this [ __ ]
somehow unlocks and a way to take a
picture okay we're gonna take a picture
of it it's gonna be hot as hell you're
gonna be a new model skin you're gonna
look fabulous
gonna make you look Freddie you got a
girl you're gonna look so good I know
you're like whispering and [ __ ] I don't
like you I don't like you at all [ __ ]
why don't you just [ __ ] off where are
you come at me bro I understand you know
I always think Oh [ __ ] [ __ ] way you
white [ __ ] the highlight here
you're spooky you're spooky all right
let's find this [ __ ]
who's gonna hand the better I got it I
did it that was in the last millisecond
of a split banana split yeah I was
really terrifying if you want to play
without if you don't have an oculus you
can still do it there's a multiplayer
coming out we should be pretty awesome I
I'm curious what that is yeah I hope you
both enjoy watching maybe like if you
did it helps out a lot I really
appreciate all the support you must get
it's the sky Tacoma red today and I'll
see you in the next one
[Music]